uh leading up to election night we
talked to some businesses here in the
valley there have been some
reports around the country about
concerns about the
effects of the election and potential uh
protesting violence
did you see anything around the valley
did metro have to deal with anything
last night
no um surprisingly we didn't um i was
we were basing everything off what you
heard and what you just
described and we thought we were going
to have some concerns with the
anarchists just disrupting the polling
locations but thankfully we didn't we
had a you know very comprehensive plan
put in place uh
in conjunction with the secretary of
state and the attorney general and
we ensured that we had officers
available in case we were called and
thankfully nothing happened so that
gives me some
pride and you know our community and
people how they deal with the
what's going on in the nation so but yet
we still have a couple days to go
obviously because decisions haven't been
completely made
and hopefully um it's not contested and
which causes
uh us some concerns um going forward so
we're gonna have all the resources still
in place
to deal with it for the next few days
until we can finalize the vote across
the nation and
people make a decision how they're going
to act aside from this
potential issue of that business owners
at least some of them had had brought up
what kind of security did metro provide
at the polling locations to more than
120 of them around clark county
yeah that's a good question so there was
concerns that we were going to
be oppressive if we were present and
people could see us there staged at the
polling location so we made a point of
staying
out of people's view but able to respond
quickly if needed
and so it was mostly just a drive-by
type
mode that we were in just to be aware
present
and able to respond in a in a timely
manner so um
other than that that that's that's all
she wrote basically we had a
department operations center stood up
similar to what we do with new year's
eve so we have a lot of resources
to bear if needed uh via a phone call a
quick phone call we can
and bring all those resources to play
and we had you know
internally uh the detectives were all
outfitted in uniforms in case we needed
to respond
in a timely manner similar to what we do
with other major events like new year's
eve so
but thankfully they were just bored and
we didn't have to go to that
uh go that direction they were the only
ones who were bored yesterday i think
given what was going on